[Music]
ladies and gentlemen my next guest is a
talented comedian who's making his
television debut with us tonight and can
be seen headlining the acme comedy club
in minneapolis on may 8th and 9th please
welcome very funny sy amundsen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody how you doing
good good
well i have some big family news my
sister is pregnant
yes
that's the good news
the bad news she likes to talk to me
about the pregnancy
she uses pregnancy terms that i don't
necessarily know the definition of
swallows wind up looking like a [ __ ] in
our conversation the other day she's
like sai we're thinking about having an
all natural childbirth
what do you think of all natural births
psy
oh yes
totally all natural so
you can have it in a field or a nest or
[Music]
deliver down at whole foods i would
presume
not what she meant by all natural she
meant she wanted to have the baby at her
house
not a hospital with no doctors and no
medicine
yeah
she wanted to do it herself studio
audience
here's the catch three weeks ago i
watched her try to get an eggo waffle
out of her toaster with a steak knife
think that officially makes you
under-qualified
in the something stuck in something else
what should i do category
i just think there are certain people
who shouldn't be allowed to have
children right at the top of that list
one of my best friends zach called me
recently said psy great news my
girlfriend and i are going to try to
have a baby
here's my issue with them in the past
six months zach and his girlfriend have
had
three kittens die on them
yeah oh no is right sad faces
i didn't say three old cats die on them
like i'm old time to die
nope
i didn't say three kittens in one
multi-kitten tragedy
uh-uh
they bought a kitten and it died so they
went out and bought a second kitten and
it died
so they went out and bought a third
kitten
and it
died the scale of things that are hard
to take care of
kitten
not very
baby
very
more importantly though on the scale of
the amount of trouble you get in if
those things die
kitten
hardly any
baby the most
a legally punishable amount of trouble
the only thing that's worse
bald eagle
that's right usa number one
here's an important piece of information
if you don't want to have a baby i
repeat if you do not want to put a baby
in a lady
you have to take precautions doesn't
always go the way you plan for example
recently a past girlfriend of mine and i
we're about to have some adult time you
know taking her to doink town
we're all out of condoms because i'm a
stud
welcome to the show
so she suggested we use the pull out
method
silence that's the right response to
that
i might be fortunate i had never had to
partake in that particular method before
but she was adamant so the two of us set
a course
towards pulloutsville
that's a lot of pressure
you have to be really good at timing
that's like going to a gas station with
just a 20 bill in your pocket
and you're pumping away and you know if
you don't stop right on that 20
if you go even one cent over when you're
going to pay they give you a baby
[Applause]
much like the excited clapper over there
i can't have a baby guys
i'm not mature enough i'm still obsessed
with pranks
i recently won a prank war let you guys
in on how i did it the guy was pranking
against zach you remember him the human
cat murdering machine
fast fact about zach he's also a
blackout drunk wonderful parenting trait
real father figure
one evening after he passed out went
over to my uncle's house he's a
taxidermist
important piece of information about
taxidermist they have what's called a
throwaway pile where people put dead
animals they decide not to mount
so we loaded into my truck
monkey
parrot badger raccoon two cougars
and a bear
brought the animals back
strategically placed them all throughout
zach's living room
even put one of the cougars up spooning
with his passed out body on the couch
and to really top things off and mess
with his mind in the middle of the room
we put a jumanji board
science guys enjoy your night
hey
that's funny oh thank you great job all
right really good job thank you stay
awesome ladies and gentlemen